[Music]
sar step out in the desert for more
Coachella fun and shanking my girl you
know I want you tell I was am named for
somebody like me
that's Hailee Steinfeld nailing a cover
of Ed Sheeran's hip song shape of you
while performing at The Hideaway on
Friday then there's Selena Gomez and The
Weeknd who continued to be inseparable
can't keep my hands to myself the couple
can't seem to get enough of each other
Selena sporting a floral sundress and
sneakers while her beau wore trendy
sunglasses a pattern button up and
ripped jeans another pair packin on the
PDA Scott Eastwood walking hand-in-hand
with his girlfriend Maddie at the neon
carnival and eye witness tells ichi they
were spotted kissing in the VIP section
adding quote they were very intimate all
night it's amazing that we happen to do
this together and Leonardo DiCaprio
enjoyed a low-key guys night with newly
single Orlando Bloom the actors kept a
low profile Leo in a sweater and
baseball cap both with their hoodies
pulled up
[Music]
you